kennt ihr das wenn die welt kopf steht
neber mal wirklich viele wissen
vielleicht gar nicht dass das bild das
in unserem auge auf unsere netzhaut
trifft verkehrt herum ist ja also
eigentlich würdet ihr die welt über kopf
sehen eure augenlinsen sind ähnlich wie
bei diesem objektiv hier sieht man jetzt
auch meine augenbrauen anstatt oben euer
hirn trägt das einfach nicht so unnormal
und die um karies erzeugt jetzt im
prinzip dem normalzustand indem sie das
bild einfach wieder umgelegt und mit
dieser brille nicht fantastisch
ausgesehen bekommen habt kann ich als
herausfinden wie sich dieser normalen
zustand eigentlich anfühlt und jetzt
wird es richtig großen sich wenn man so
eine brille lang genug trägt und alles
kopf übersehen sagt unser gehirn
irgendwann wieder dafür dass das wieder
umgedreht wird damit ihr es richtig
sehen das heißt wenn man sie dann wieder
abnimmt sieht man wieder alles kopfüber
und das ohne den drill und na ja also
das würde mir extrem viel angst machen
man müsste die welt also wieder so lange
verkehrte hunger tragen bis das gehirn
also wieder zurück spiegelt und jetzt
herauszufinden wie das wäre wenn wir
wirklich alles kopfüber sehen also so
wie das bild auf unsere netzhaut trifft
werden jetzt ab sofort diese umkehr
brille tragen wie kann ich damit
überhaupt gehen trinken packen steigen
zeichnen was passiert wenn ich einen
handstand nachher wo ich ohnehin schon
kopfüber bin und das dann ja wieder
umkehre dann wir finden heraus die zeit
gilt ab jetzt moment nach oben bewegt
bewegt sich alles nach unten
ja ich sehe meine hände meine hände
kommen von oben rein das ist als würde
man sich von außerhalb anschauen also
ich fühle mich noch irgendwie drauf da
ist
[Musik]
wir sagen wir fangen wir an zu zeichnen
oder ich dachte ich sage das sehr
schlimm aber es ist einfach super cool
hier wird tatsächlich ein bisschen
schwindlig ja doch ehrlich spürst das
war eine ganz schlechte idee die auch
ein paar wie ihr hier seht kann man die
prismen in der brille auch drehen und
damit das bild nicht nur von oben nach
unten sondern auch von links nach rechts
spiegeln um das im alltag vielleicht
sogar noch viel schlimmer ist erfahrt
ihr im video von texas steht die idee zu
diesem gemeinsamen projekt handle
dieses video wird unterstützt von blink
ist ich zeige noch mal ein haus okay
let's go will das haus kirchentür
jörg nowka ihr könnt nicht vor schwierig
das ist ja echt sein ist es leichter das
ist ein gutes haus kreis zu malen häufig
schwierig juni im kreis mal landkreis
[Musik]
geht normal weiter jetzt mal richtig
konzentrieren
ich weiß wo ich habe was ich sehe ist
genau vor wir wollen muss nah wie du ich
bin im kreis schaffen einfach
der us-soldat also ich darf mich nicht
darauf verlassen was ich sehe ich muss
immer noch gefühle ein kreis meine jetzt
geht vielleicht ein bisschen durst und
bitte nichts verschütten
so also hier ist ja aus meiner linken
hand das schon meiner rechten hand ich
muss jetzt nichts machen als es zu
schütten
das sollte ja hahaha
das wasser fliesst kopf über mein gott
denn dass sie das heißt jetzt provoziert
ich wollte zum coolen mut machen hier
aber das sieht so geil aus wenn was
haben oben fließt und wichtigste frage
ist eine mitgeben kann ich glaube das
wird sogar ein so schwierig
es schweben
das ist sogar das sieht einfach aus als
würde der decke gehen
das ist weil man sich so von vorne sieht
ich sehe so als würde ich vor mir es
würde aber vor mir stehen das ist das
also ich find gehen
ok ich suche jetzt erst mal ein
schreibtischstuhl hier wenn ich heute
noch arbeiten müssen
ok ich glaube doch nicht da sieht man
über sein
[Musik]
das ist nicht so gut ich ziehe mich
ziemlich alt der decken aber es sieht
aus als wenn ich mich zu boden ziehen
über normalen handstand machen
das ist extrem coole art und weise in
hand schon zu weil man einfach nicht
immer kommt übersieht aber ich glaube es
reicht auch schon
na ja aber ich merke halt tatsächlich
total seine unfassbar anstrengend ist
und ja schon richtig müde bin muss ich
ständig nachdenken bei jedem buch was
nicht automatisch meine pause echt jetzt
[Musik]
was man ja gerade auch aufgefallen ist
dass unsere gene irgendwie das was wir
sehen halt stabilisierte lebenshaltung
das vorhersehen kann wie wir uns den
kopf bewegen und dann da sehen wir dass
ausgleich zu im kopf und das passiert
einfach deutlich weniger also ich packe
ich einmal alles weil wie sie mein kopf
hat bewegt nicht für das bild sorgt was
man als erwartet und das hat dann nicht
mehr so stabilisieren kann vermutlich
jetzt mal gar nicht mal sagen in dem
lustigen ich habe tatsächlich
mittlerweile ein bisschen hunger also
ich muss jetzt einerseits die treppe
herunter gehen was schon mal eine
richtige trend wird und andererseits das
kochen für anträge way alter wichtig
höhenangst es sieht aus als würde ich
als welche art von dem richtigen abgrund
einfach um mein gott
ihr müsst wissen dass ich hier
regelmäßig runterfallen und das ohne
sonnenbrille
diese recht rutschig treffen ist eine
super idee mich hin und her zu lassen
das erstmal müssen wir paar zwiebeln
schneiden oder die zwiebel schneiden sie
monate mal meine hand mal so dass mich
entscheiden kann wie ich hoffe dass ich
ein bisschen angeles kommt wird falsch
geschnitten
bevor er weiß was ein defekt ist dass
ich jetzt nicht weine mit der zwiebel
rechner brille im weg ab weiß was man
echt ziemlich angst macht am anfang ist
die brille aufgesetzt habe an meine
augen sich gar nicht so richtig schön
übereinander gelegt java zwei bilder
gesehen die so ein bisschen übereinander
geleert waren ab jetzt sehe ich ein
glasklares bild und das kann ich nur
dadurch erklären dass meine augen als
comics sind ich bin wirklich gespannt
was passiert wenn ich das ding immer
wieder abnehmen so das muss reichen
warum das ist richtig so das geht jetzt
auch wieder schwierig das weiß man nicht
wo sie gehen
[Gelächter]
so kann das hier nicht anbrennt sie sind
eben hier schon dünnsten sie glasig
werden hierbei tom waits kochshow
gegenüber zwiebeln und patrick schade
drin aber damit muss ich leben
[Musik]
wohl dosiert das ist richtig hält oh
mein gott
[Musik]
ab und setze mir ein bisschen zu viel
gekocht habe ich glaube dass guy wyser
schafhalter let's go ich habe richtig
bock aber ich glaube es geht also links
und rechts gleich mitfahren und decke
aber bei mario kart achters sehen wir
das problem dass seine weggefährten
zurück
ohne witz das geht häufig boa der da
willst du dritter alter bis direkt
hinter mir war weiter einfach besser als
sonst nur hallo
ach so ich bin ja ich 250 die zeit ein
bisschen fallschirm aus nein also fast
ein uhr nachts man sagen sind gezählt
weil man kann wirklich einfach
logischerweise mit seiner brille gar nix
machen produktiv sowieso überhaupt nicht
mag hat ging halbwegs eine sache die
nicht so eingetreten wie es mir dachte
ist dass das ganze deutlich
anstrengender die länger man s macht ich
dachte eigentlich und gewöhnt sich
einfach dran aber es wird einfach immer
anstrengender weil wirklich jede sekunde
muss ich einfach nicht kommen da
konzentrieren und meinen hier muss so
viel transferleistung machen und das
alles um zu rechnen und je länger das
macht das du kaputt als magier und da so
schlecht also es auch und das finde ich
es mir und ja deswegen ist der plan ist
es ist ein uhr nachts ich bin müde
wiegenstein und ich schlafe jetzt
hoffentlich bis morgen 14 uhr
da werde ich dann möglichst schnell raus
noch eine treppe runtergehen
nur in pc ganz gefüllt mit dem mégane an
der treppe daran habe ich auch vor weit
weg bin das ich fühle mich echt als
welchem welt als meinen augen zu weil
ich weiß eigentlich in der treppe
funktioniert aber je mehr ich sehe dass
zu verwehren da ist es wirklich ich sehe
nichts mehr zu einem spiegel dass wir
sagen ganz nett aus das ist so verrückt
das ist so krass war wenn ihr eure haben
jetzt mal hoch hebt dann seht ihr denn
von unten rein kommen aber wenn ich
meine arme hoch hebt dann kommen die von
oben ins bild rein
der tag ist eigentlich vorbei das aber
zu gut
doch nicht
okay ich habe mich den anschein knopf
gefunden gucken morgen das ist ultra wie
ein bisschen früher aufgemacht als ich
dachte ich wollte eigentlich erst jetzt
hier 10 uhr aufstehen damit ich das
möglich meint er mich schrecklich wenn
die zeit rum bringen bücher haben ja
auch wieder hinlegen muss auch ganz kurz
einmal gc war war das ist es wirklich
als wenn man in einer welt die treppe ja
so habe ich die treppe halt so
jetzt geht es eigentlich gerade schon
halbwegs wieder gut da wir jetzt zehn
stunden schlafen und dadurch konnten wir
wieder ein bisschen pause machen hat
jetzt jedoch wieder ein bisschen power
für alles kopfüber zu denken und
irgendwie doppelt zu verarbeiten
das ist so cool ihr müsst das mal
vorstellen weil ich sehe dass halt alles
so und es sieht aus als würde man ja
natürlich diese deckenbeleuchtung und
durch diese ganzen lametta sachen aber
durch schweben fünf wortreich ja jetzt
seit ziemlich genau 24 stunden diese
brille drauf was jetzt passieren wird
wenn ich die abnehmen ich habe keine
ahnung ich nehme es mal ab ich sehe ich
sie also doppelt meinen augen kommt
gerade haupt nicht drauf klar dass ich
mein ja und kommt überhaupt nicht klar
dass ich habe schwierigkeiten noch sagen
zu fokussieren weil aber auch diese
prismen sind nicht perfekt übereinander
wie gesagt die beiden bilder die man
sieht sie ein bisschen versetzt gewesen
sie haben wir ja auch ganz glaube ich so
gefühlt denn hier machen müssen um die
bilder doch zusammenzufügen und jetzt in
meine augen immer noch ein bisschen auf
aber ich glaube daran gewöhne ich mich
genauso schnell wie ich mich daran
gewöhnt hat woran ich mich gar nicht
gewöhnen muss ist das jetzt wieder der
boden am boden dass es macht aber auch
soviel sind gehen wir es wissen
schwindelig tatsächlich das schnelle
aufstehen war nicht so gut bin immer
dankbar ist fühlt sich einfach immer
wirklich toll an nach 6 prozent waren
doch alle sind komplett eingeschränkt
war wieder normal laufen zu können wie
normaler mensch wertschätzt das einfach
wie schön es ist einfach normales dasein
gerade zu haben und aber nicht irgendein
geschwenkt zu sein
also ja das hat mir sehr geholfen die
kleinen dinge im leben selbst wertet
eigentlich war mit brille viel besser
die letzten 24 stunden deutlich gezeigt
wie leicht es ist mein eigenes gehirn
aus dem gleichgewicht zu bringen im
alltag reicht aber meist einiges weniger
um die konzentration zu verlieren um in
der heutigen zeit der permanenten
ablenkung bei der sache zu bleiben kann
ich euch das buch konzentration von
marco münchhausen empfehlen links bringt
die kernaussagen von über 3.000 sagt
mich an in kompakten 15 minuten links
direkt auf dein smartphone und das
sowohl als text zum lesen als auch als
audio zum hören und dass dann sogar ein
doppelter geschwindigkeit dadurch dann
sogar nur siebeneinhalb minuten wenn er
das möchte
womit man dann natürlich in extrem
kurzer zeit unfassbar viel wissen zu den
themen finanzen psychologie
persönlichkeitsentwicklung
unternehmertum wissenschaft und viele
mehr aufsaugen kann sowohl auf deutsch
und auch auf englisch über den link
linke.de / turnier in der video
finden könnt könnt ihr sieben tage lang
link ist kostenlos testen und wenn auch
das dann gefällt bekommt ihr über den
link in der infobox 25 prozent rabatt
auf das jahres-abo blinkt ist premium
das war's dann damit auch von diesem
video wenn ihr das nächste nicht
verpassen möchte abonniert gerne diesen
kanal schaut auch gerne auf einem zweig
einer für beide posten täglichen video
und jetzt geht es weiter mit dem video
von hectas tisch in dem er die brille
zeitverträgen
[Musik]